all right Sophie yes Sophie where you
from originally where did you grow up
Brooklyn from Brooklyn Brooklyn girl and
tell me about your uh your family
growing
up
um what do you want to know you had Mom
and Dad yeah I lived with u my mom and
dad until 5 we moved to Brooklyn when I
was 5 but we lived a few different
places bounced around my dad's a
basketball coach so he has taken like a
million different jobs since as a baby
how would you describe your childhood in
general solid I was financially
supported completely I I think I got
everything I ever wanted physically but
emotionally I struggle with mental
health I didn't know it until like 16
but I how old are you now 19
um yeah
I have I had un diagnosed bipolar 2 so
looking back I'm like that explains so
much but as a kid I didn't know what was
going on I was just unusually mopy but
then but most of the time people saw me
as like the the kind of mask that I put
on like the very outgoing and social is
the majority of your mental problems uh
that you're by polar or are there other
things too uh at first I have ADHD um
but at first it was I got diagnosed with
depression like severe depression and
they gave me anti-depressants for
it and somehow the chemicals like the it
goes to the wrong receptor I don't know
the doctor was talking me about I wasn't
really listening but the parts I did
hear was that it was like [__] up
my [__] up my depression even worse
it seems like the doctors the psych
doctors are just stabbing in the dark at
what medications to
prescribe they just throw [__] out there
they're like let's try that and I was on
so many different anti-depressants for
years and I didn't know it was like
making it work like I'm on mood
stabilizers that's what I need to be on
it's not
like depression all the time it comes in
waves but this is not from some
childhood trauma or anything like that I
don't know
I I have memories of being molested as a
child but I don't have like
full I have some flashbacks but I never
had them as a kid like that wasn't
something that I just avidly talked
about or even thought about like it
wasn't until I went to treatment for the
first time at like 17 where I started
having flashbacks cuz that was like
first time I was sober since I was I
don't know 12 11 what did you start
using at 12 11
um nicotine started with the nicotine
and alcohol that it was definitely
alcohol first but my parents
were Drinker my mom's not so much of a
drinker but my stepdad is a heavy
drinker and so is my father I don't know
my father figures are
um
questionable um did alcohol lead to
something else or for
me yeah um
eventually I moved to Tampa during
Co and I started I was smoking weed at
the time I remember when I moved to
Tampa like my biggest concern was
finding a plug I was like I need to have
some sort of substance I'm not going to
this place with no friends sober that's
ridiculous you got me
Twisted so I found a plug that was my
first thing and then I I was still 15 16
and I was supposed to be a junior in
high school but I dropped out I didn't
give a [__] about school I just got high
in the bathroom all the time I think
that was also the year I started
bringing like whiskey in water bottles
and pouring it in my coffee was just
nasty like I don't even really like
whiskey you just want to get drunk yeah
I'm not even I'm not that much of an
alcohol person when I
found um pills downers were like my best
friend because I just wanted to like
completely remove myself from
life I just wanted to be non-existent
were there friends and classmates you
had back then that were also into these
things uh I met one friend I went to one
class it was theater class and I don't
think I ever attended another class in
full um but I met one friend she
introduced me to a bunch of other people
and that was like my Inn in Florida I
was like okay now I got the connections
[__] school like I don't need it anymore
I found my friends I found the thing I'm
G to do I'm just going to do drugs and
so it wasn't very
common ah it was very common I just
didn't know anybody yet oh I see it's
drugs are crazy in Florida they
are
uh is the biggest issue
for teenagers right now I I I assume I
mean the amount of uh Adolescent
Treatment Facility like adolescent
rehabs like with ranging from 12 to
18yar olds like there's 12y olds who are
who have done heroin like shit's real
and I I've seen it like in person like
some of these a lots of a lot of group
therapy um I heard some of these wild
stories
like oh my gosh I there's not just one
to choose but some interesting
characters too I think I don't even know
if
I I feel like that might have [__] up
my mental health a little bit more like
being tossed into a community of all
struggling children why do you think
there are so many young teens that are
into this kind of
stuff
I mental I think mental health I that's
got to be the number one cause it's
escaping something you can't control why
do you think there are so many young
teens then that are having struggling
with mental
health because like when when I when I
was your age I don't remember a whole
lot of my classmates and friends that
were
dependent on anything like this I mean
I'm sure there were some but not was it
just not your
crowd no I mean I knew everybody then so
it's like it
was
certain you know maybe it's more
prevalent I never I never got involved
but maybe it was more prevalent than
more common that I than I thought I it
must have been I think it's just more
talked about now like think is more
popular now yeah on on social media I I
diagn self diagnose myself all the time
I'm like oh [__] I must have this
disorder now because I have like two of
the two of the 10 symptoms but people
are just diagnosing themselves with
bogus cuz they saw it on Tik Tok and
they don't actually see a professional
and they want an excuse to use what they
want to use yeah it's yeah yeah um I had
a friend I started doing Xanax when I
was 16 in Florida
I got intro introduced to a girl um she
was 22
so little bit older than me six years um
but she had a 90day script for Xanax and
she had severe anxiety PTSD she saw her
boyfriend get shot a few years prior
like bled out in her arms so I was like
oh that makes sense like yeah you have a
right to get drugs you have you're it's
okay to be an addict if you have PTSD I
don't know but her mom also had the same
prescription and they would take each
other's pills like if somebody ran out
the other one was taking the pills and
by month month one they'd be out so they
still got like two more months un
unmedicated you I don't think anybody
actually needs anx there's so many other
anxiety medications how did your family
deal with your drug
[Music]
problems I so I dropped out of high
school and I was allegedly going to GED
classes I went to a few of those and
just I said I was going to school then I
went out for the school day did whatever
smoked a lot of weed drank a lot of
alcohol um was doing
Xanax and then I would come home be like
okay I just got home from school grab a
bag and then go sleep over a friend's
house for several days I just completely
ignored my parents I
wasn't um engaging in any family
activities like no family dinner and
that was like that's our thing as
Italians you
everybody has big family
dinners and and you moved back from
Florida to uh New York area
yeah it's been a lot
from 16 so I started taking Xanax my
friend when her and her mom would run
out of scripts they would go by Street
Xanax which at the top still is but
laced with
fentanyl
and I had started taking her
prescription pills but when she ran out
of those she started giving me the
straight ones and
those almost always had fit in all and
like a tiny quarter would get you so
[__] up you'd be blacked out for
like I remember taking a half of a Xanax
bar
fentel and I passed out for like 22
hours my mom was like checking my
pulse I don't know
there's three to four four months that I
just don't remember
from uh like six the end of my 16th year
alive and then into my 17th birthday oh
[__] but I I don't know drugs have given
me the memory of a [__]
goldfish um I went to treatment four
days after my 17th birthday I got Baker
acted which is like a 5150 but in
Florida they I took all my xanaxs I
called my
brother
and um I say Xanax but they were they
were laced pills it was like straight up
fentol and I was like yeah I'm just
taking anxiety meds that were not
prescribed like pressed by a [__]
plug that I just bought it from like I
was delusional I was was convincing
myself
and yeah 4 days after my 17th birthday I
took what I had left of the
pills and I also had like a little pill
of Molly which was not Molly either like
it was meth like everything's laced with
every like Street jugs are just I know
when old people say back in my day like
weed was a lot stronger or oh no weed
was a lot less strong like nothing is
the same anymore like weeds being laced
I guess I've never had my weed laced
I'll would be glad when I was when I was
into drugs if my weed was laced with
fentanyl I'd be like oh free [__] that's
just how [__] up my mind was it was
anything free any free drugs like I
would hang out with men just for their
pills or for a place to sleep even
though I
had a very comfortable home with my mom
and my dad still lived in Brooklyn like
I always had places to go I just didn't
want it like I didn't I didn't want the
help I wanted to be isolated I wanted to
be like an independent woman but I had
no resources I wasn't financially stable
emotionally
stable physically I was [__] up too I
was like 40
lbs lighter and unhealthy I lost my ass
I was I turned around the mirror I was
like where did it go it's like damn I've
been [__] up for so long what do you
think was drive driving your that
mindset you just become self-destructive
or yeah I wanted
to not exist in that
reality I didn't have any future plans I
was living every day like it was my last
which I don't do anymore I used to think
it was a good thing like that's like
party till you drop but no that's I I I
kind of like live for tomorrow I'm like
what am I doing tomorrow like what am I
going to cook for dinner I feel like a
40-year-old woman with kids I don't have
kids I just I'm just living but I feel
like I like but you've been through a
lot for 19y
old yeah and i' I've been in countless
facilities I
think
about 15 different rehabs sober livings
detoxes all those mixed in one did any
of them
work out of the 15 I think there was one
I know there was one that really helped
me in Florida and it was weird too it
was um harm reduction so it's not like
it's typical rehab like there's people
smoking weed in the rehab that's the
only thing you can do it's marijuana
maintenance so you can get your medical
card you can smoke weed and stay sober
off whatever else you're coming from I
don't know but it was helpful um Synergy
it
was a wakeup call
I I was
very isolated there from my family my
mom was still in Florida but she was in
Tampa and I was in Lantana so they're
kind of like a a little ways away from
each other it's like right in the middle
of Tampa and Mi and Miami like Fort
Lauderdale that area a little bit closer
to Miami but I was living in a house
with
strangers older people I think I was
like the youngest one for a while but I
don't know living with adults was good
and bad at that place it was good cuz I
met a lot of people and I still have
healthy relationships with them but I
got my [__] together there so so you got
clean in
Florida I don't even know I the last
time I used fentanyl was over a year ago
but I still I still drank I still smoke
weed I'm not completely sober people are
like oh you're cie sober I'm not sober
by any means I'm just not doing the
hardest
pills yeah and it was forced into my
brain holy [__] these places some a lot
of them forced AA I was like their big
thing the big book
Thumpers
and they basically say that you can't
Step One is powerless over we admit to
ourselves that we were powerless over
drugs and alcohol and I could never get
past that step I was like am I powerless
I really it was always a battle like do
I want to stop do I not want to stop
because I was forced into these places
as a kid like it was never my
choice what what helped you what what
thinking helped
you I
think I at one point I was running away
I wanted to go to re that was like the
first time I wanted to go back to rehab
because I was so terrified I was in Bay
Ridge still living there but this is
about
um two years ago I was on pills and I
was back in
Brooklyn living with my dad I got kicked
out of my mom's house after moving back
with her after after another
rehab
and I was hanging out with like
everybody in anybody like anyone who
would just go out with me or I could go
to their house like I just didn't want
to be at home and my friend was like you
just have to go like it's 4:00 in the
morning like stop trying
to go to New Jersey like you don't know
anybody there like you're just meeting
people on Tinder like this is ridiculous
and I was like no I don't want to go
home but I had a great house my dad
drinks which is
worrisome sometimes but it's out of my
control I can't do [__] how much grown
ask how much of your drug use and all
that was a product
of just teenage low
self-worth
I think a lot a lot I had no self worth
I
was I I haven't found it until recently
like
I didn't care about who I was sleeping
with I was selling my body for drugs
which is something I don't think I've
ever admitted out loud but I was doing
that for money or for
pills um I never in a million years
thought that that's where I would be I
used to watch these videos well I still
do but like three years ago I was
watching a prostitute on your channel I
was like damn that can never be me
[__] it was me it's
me um but yeah I just found myself in so
many [__] up situations I never meant
to get myself into but that's what
happens see yeah is there a part of you
that's like like attracted to that
dangerous destructive
lifestyle yeah
100% I think about it every day I
struggle I want to
self-destruct for no reason like there's
I I feel like
I I [__] things up for myself like
things are going really well I'm in an
apprentice ship I'm working
like saving money and planning on moving
out
um and I'm waiting for something to go
wrong like it hasn't been like this
for ever like I've never been mentally
stable and
sober at the same time sober I'm not
sober but not
on drugs constantly or drinking
constantly like it was always something
like if I wasn't on pills then I was
doing abnormal amounts of
cocaine and what is it called there's a
a chemical that cocaine and alcohol coca
coca ethanol something like that but
like it's addicting like that
combination like once you have it
together it's like I can't have one or
the other it's like you need both your
brain tells you that you know [__]
need anything um
but that's that's where my brain resided
for 18
years oh yeah we're talking about
um what kind of made it click I don't
people always talk about having this
spiritual experience this Godlike
experience but I don't believe in God I
don't really believe in anything like
that I
I don't know I didn't have one of those
kinds of experiences though it was
mostly trying to escape a physical
problem like in in Brooklyn I was caught
up with these crazy ass [__] I
didn't know they were pimps until
they're trying to pit me out like this
[__] always happened to me like I got
myself in the worst situations you're
hanging out with the wrong crowd yeah
like why was I hanging out with
25-year-olds like as a
16-year-old as a 19-year-old I wouldn't
even hang out with a 16-year-old it's
weird like there's there's it's
offputting it's not there's a different
maturity level it's
just it's a little unsettling to look
back at the people who were like feeding
me drugs at their age like to a 15 16
old do do you find yourself getting
mellower and maybe a little wiser now
that you're of the ripe old ripe old age
of 19 yeah 19 feeling
42 maybe I've gotten Wier I've been able
to articulate my feelings a lot better
[__] four years of
therapy finally
got
my emotions aligned with my m MTH like I
can speak what I'm [__] feeling
finally is therapy
helping yeah I go every week
it's eye
opening I try to not push but advise
everyone to get therapy cuz even if
you're not
like if you you don't have to like go
through something extremely traumatic to
then say Oh I need therap therapy
because of this like everyone's got got
to talk to somebody and they're like a
third party they have nothing to do with
your life they don't know anybody you
know there's no ties I mean you got to
pay them but insurance if you don't have
insurance
um I don't know that's hard I
wish I wish things like therapy were
more easily accessible to
everybody are you on
medications I'm on mood
stabilizers finally I'm not like
completely explosive or completely in a
depressive
episode I'm in between I still feel
emotions it's not like taking away your
emotions it's just making you more aware
of your of how your emotions are
affecting
you oh my God gosh I I really I can't
wait to get out of Brooklyn I this whole
week I have not left my house and if I
did leave I walked like to the Dunkin
Donuts or to the bagel store I'm just
like so paranoid of these people in my
neighborhood coming to find me and it's
not it's not totally justified I mean
I've gotten death threats by this so
this man the one I was hanging out with
um the 24
25 uh mid 20s I don't [__] know but I
got introduced to him by a friend who
was my friend in high school that friend
had another friend who had a boyfriend
so it was not even like my friend's
friend it was like my friend's friend's
boyfriend like all these ties so I
didn't know him at all
and he said he was going to buy me drugs
so I hung out with
him um his girlfriend was like in the
front seat when I got in the car and she
was like passed out drunk he was like
I'm just going to take her home and then
we'll hang out I was like okay like
you're still going to buy me the drugs
right
and yeah obviously he wanted to drug a
16-year-old girl like vulnerable naive
want need something from
you so I oh my God I stupidly went back
to his house and I thought it was just
going to be me and him I just thought I
was going to be doing this other girl
dirty I was like I don't know her but
I'm going to steal her man that's what I
was thinking I was like oh I'm just
going to hook up with this
guy and I went inside the apartment and
before we went in I looked at him like
before he was opening the door I was
like don't let anything happen to me
like don't let anything bad happen to me
I just taken the xana he bought me and I
think those were real cuz I didn't like
completely pass out I was just not
completely there um but I walked in the
door and there was three guys sitting on
the couch I was like what the [__] is
this I thought it was going to be like a
a a porn shoe I was like what the [__]
going on I don't see the cameras
anywhere am I getting punked no it
wasn't a punk they were just that's just
what they did they hung out with young
girls
and
they I don't know what you call like
initiated them like but that was it like
I never I never talked I did talk to
them again
um I got gang raped in his apartment by
these men oh and they
they took my underwear and my pants that
I was wearing and I don't know what they
did with them maybe they kept them as
like trophies they're [__] weird and
they showered me like they threw me in
the shower I was like I don't want to
take a shower I was just laying on the
floor
afterwards and I was
like traumatized dissociated like I was
not there on drugs like all the above
and I was not having it so they like
grabbed me and physically put me in the
shower and then I fell asleep in
someone's bed I think the boyfriend of
the friend's friend I slept in his bed
and I woke up with him on top of me I
was like what the [__] is going on like
where am I I was hella confused in the
morning I didn't know where the [__] I
was it's like Whose Bed am I
in and I see this big ass man on top of
me I'm like oh [__] what the [__] is
going on I realized he's like having sex
with me I was like this ain't right well
you're passed out yeah I woke up to him
inside me I was just like I was very
confused and then uh he
finished and then I grabbed my
stuff and and I walked through the
hallway and I saw the living room and
there were just these three buffoons and
they were eating Popeyes like so
casually I looked at them I was
like okay wow I just walked out the door
said nothing they let me leave I was
tell me tell me the guy was wearing a
condo shocked I have no
idea I have no idea no clue no
clue um that was never a concern either
like I I have an IUD so I'm like that
makes me Invincible but there's get
[__] AIDS like with the men I
was in relationships with I guess that's
what you call customers whatever uh
they're older they old men and I don't
know there's a lot of young I haven't
met anyone who's my age with AIDS or HIV
like it just
hasn't or nobody is told me
but I'm assuming that older men might
are more likely to carry herpes any kind
of disease because they have more sexual
experience unless they're a virgin and
then
that's I don't know why a virgin would
be soliciting
sex actually that makes sense I know why
would be soliciting sex from a young
girl Sophie what would you say is your
biggest
regret no
regrets I I feel like I wouldn't
be if that question is so difficult cuz
obviously I want to change a lot of [__]
but I would still be in that mindset
like I still be doing the same
things you've learned from some of your
mistakes yeah yeah I'm still learning
growing but
I don't know it's really hard to trust
men I'm on this whole like [__] men
Rampage and then I realize
like it's just the men who [__] me
over but I'm trying to I can't date I
can't do any of that [__] right now
because I'm so focused on myself like I
can I can talk to a man for like 2 days
and I will completely lose track like
something about Rel relationship I have
hypersexuality so with trauma
there's not only two directions but the
two most common directions are like
cutting yourself off from any sexual
activity or hyper oppos sexuality yeah
the complete opposite and I went the
hyper route and just started having sex
with anybody and
everybody and
fell into some [__] like that like I
kept ending up in these [__]
situations I I was working at a smoke
shop in
Brooklyn and um the I walked in I had
never been to this m sh like never
purchased anything from them I was like
looking for a job and that seemed like
an easy job to me so I walked in I was
looking for quick money wanted my pills
wanted to get money the same day I was
working
um so that was my strategy I walked in
he was like you're hired come in for
training tomorrow I was wearing like
this crop top and like booty shorts I
was like I know I'm going to get it I
know I'm going to get the job cuz I seen
the man in the Windows like
he's I I at that point I understood men
and their desire for younger
females um but he hired me on spot
and I didn't even notice any red flags
but there were a lot of them he like
bought me alcohol on
shift
and bought bought pills and things his
friends would come into the shop a lot
and I it' just be me working there but
he'd send his friends in to come check
on me but it was always a new friend
so I did not realize what he was doing
at the time but come to find out that's
like his whole thing like he hires young
girls
he lures them into this
little night night cap routine he would
like take me and my friend out my friend
would come by the shop and I was like
come work with with me come it's fun and
she was like no like that guy's weird
like I'll drink with him not going to
work there cuz she was creeped out by
him U I was not I was like I didn't care
like men already disgusted me I was like
how much worse could this get it got
worse I didn't you a chance expecting it
do you think there's a chance of you
getting back into the heavier drugs I
mean not not that alcohol isn't heavy
I could do it tomorrow I could do it
today I'm constantly scared of slipping
up
but I'm TR I'm still trying to convince
myself
that um the next time I use I'll die but
I've taken crazy amounts of these deadly
drugs and I don't know how I'm still
alive you have an
ODed no I I
think my mom thought I was going to OD
so she like brought me to the hospital
as soon as I took all my pills and they
just they watched me but I was sedated I
was I was fighting everybody in that
hospital I fought the nurses you took
you took all your pills trying to do
what I don't I told her that I wanted to
die like I
was I think I was trying to kill myself
I was so out of it I don't even remember
that she told me this later my mom's so
cute she she kept a journal she keeps a
journal she was like in the hospital
with me like so bad Sophie is getting
restrained currently she just got
sedated like oh [__] mom why did you
have this on like on paper come on but
it's for her sanity I
know I feel so bad for like the parents
that go through watching their kids cuz
I've seen the kids and I've been in
places with them and I've also seen the
parents like I've been in once I turned
18 I was in like all these adult
facilities holy [__] the stories that
came with that men are [__] weird
that's the point that's the
just base base plot of this
story
um I hope that's not the most important
lesson you've learned but what what what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life don't
trust anybody no uh be be cautious about
who
you invest your time in
even I don't even give people the time a
day most of the time like I used to cat
calling I used to stop and turn around
try to see who was like talking to me or
like when people would say like hey baby
how you doing I'd be like Oh I'm fine
now I don't respond to like any of that
[__] and I used to like think I owed
people something major people pleas
people pleaser but I don't owe anybody
[__] all right Sophie thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you I wish
you lots of luck you're you're you're
getting better I
am I hope you uh stay on that track
I will alcohol is not going to help you
at all no it's but I don't think it's
about I don't think it's about common
sense I think it's about
selfworth yeah and if you believe you
deserve a better life you'll do the
things that will bring that
about yeah 100% you'll see that alcohol
or pills or whatever is just going to
get in the way of that a lot of the kids
I was talking to they didn't see like me
they didn't see a future like there was
no it was just maybe I'll make it to
20 won't make it to 30 though so what's
the point of getting going into a trade
or starting school to have a career no
hope no point yeah it's not a good place
to be no now there's
reason hope whatever you want to call it
I've seen the light I talked to God no I
didn't I don't believe we
got all right Sophie thank you so much
thank thank
you